evans week-end festif entre trappe et la
verrière des concerts des animations et
nouveauté cette année un village de la
biodiversité à la verrière dans les
stands des représentants d'amap de
jardins collectifs et même des poules et
des chèvres moi je trouve que c'est bien
le médecin ici pour que tout le monde
connaisse le bio est la meilleure
consistance de légumes fruits
enfin fall tous et c'est meilleur pour
la santé depuis plus de 20 ans la fête
de juin c'est la fête de la musique
avant l'heure c'est vraiment la fête de
la vigne mettre en avant ce que font
toutes les associations de la ville et
donc ce qu'on fait tous les ans avec une
telle robe de 25 à 30 ans à lyon n'était
plus à 30 avec la biodiversité mais y'a
jamais on sort de 22 et 30 stands tous
les emplois qui reflète la dynamisme
associatif de la bêta
le lendemain à quelques kilomètres de là
mais pourquoi veux-tu te défiles à mon
camp mais parfois il croit qu'il voulait
dessiner je te laisse tranquille c'est
promis on attrape pendant que certains
enfile des perles
d'autres travaillent leur sens du rythme
près de 3000 personnes sont venues
profiter du spectacle attrape sur les
deux zones